artists to arrest the records and then
from aristo records i went to bad boy
records and then my career
you know took off is shaquille o'neal
and may allah be with you thank you
i mean but when i speak to him he gives
me salams
you know what i'm saying i return to
salams without you know investigating
humbly like gets along you know
is the right of a muslim to return this
at night so because we hear we hear that
shaquille o'neal i believe he is milan
knows best you know saying
i have spoken to him one time since i've
been home and he actually had contracted
covet
yeah he told me wasn't feeling well and
you know i just recently seen him pop up
in the interview so you know inshallah
i'ma reach out to him
maybe that'd be a conversation with
having death shots and for those people
that don't know
i mean muslims simply one who has
submitted his or her will to the creator
that heavens and earth
yeah so you know these are things that
constitute a person to enter the fold of
islam
by way of testifying that none has the
right to be worshipped with allah and
then muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is the messenger you
know and what follows
is you know implementation of that
understanding
so you went now from